[Applause]
thank you very much madam Speaker
mr. vice president members of Congress
the first lady of the United States
and my fellow Americans we meet tonight
at a moment of unlimited potential as we
begin a new Congress
I stand here ready to work with you to
achieve historic breakthroughs for all
Americans millions of our fellow
citizens are watching us now gathered in
this great chamber hoping that we will
govern not as two parties but as one
nation
the agenda I will lay out this evening
is not a Republican agenda or a Democrat
agenda
it's the agenda of the American people
many of us have campaigned on the same
core promises to defend American jobs
and demand fair trade for American
workers to rebuild and revitalize our
nation's infrastructure to reduce the
price of health care and prescription
drugs to create an immigration system
that is safe lawful modern and secure
and to pursue a foreign policy that puts
America's interest first there is a new
opportunity in American politics if only
we have the courage together to seize it
victory is not winning for our party
victory is winning for our country
this year America will recognize two
important anniversaries that show us the
majesty of America's mission and the
power of American pride in June we mark
75 years since the start of what General
Dwight D Eisenhower called
the Great Crusade the Allied liberation
of Europe in World War two
on d-day June 6 1944 15,000 young
American men jumped from the sky and
60,000 more stormed in from the sea to
save our civilization from tyranny here
with us tonight are three of those
incredible heroes private first class
Joseph Reilly
Staff Sergeant Irving Locker and
Sergeant Herman
zhichen
[Applause]
gentlemen we salute you in 2019 we also
celebrate 50 years since brave young
pilots flew a quarter of a million miles
through space to plant the American flag
on the face of the moon half a century
later we are joined by one of the Apollo
11 astronauts who planted that flag Buzz
Aldrin
Thank You buzz this year American
astronauts will go back to space on
American Rockets
in the twentieth century America saved
freedom transform science redefined the
middle class and when you get down to it
there's nothing anywhere in the world
that can compete with America
now we must step boldly and bravely into
the next chapter of this great American
adventure and we must create a new
standard of living for the 21st century
an amazing quality of life for all of
our citizens is within reach we can make
our community safer our family stronger
our culture richer our faith deeper and
our middle-class bigger and more
prosperous than ever before
but we must reject the politics of
revenge resistance and retribution and
embrace the boundless potential of
cooperation compromise and the common
good
together we can break decades of
political stalemate we can bridge all
divisions heal old wounds build new
coalition's forge new solutions and
unlock the extraordinary promise of
America's future the decision is ours to
make we must choose between greatness or
gridlock results or resistance vision or
vengeance incredible progress or
pointless destruction tonight I ask you
to choose greatness
over the last two years my
administration has moved with urgency
and historic speed to confront problems
neglected by leaders of both parties
over many decades in just over two years
since the election we have launched an
unprecedented economic boom a boom that
has rarely been seen before there's been
nothing like it we have created 5.3
million new jobs and importantly added
600,000 new manufacturing jobs something
which almost everyone said was
impossible to do but the fact is we are
just getting started
wages are rising at the fastest pace in
decades and growing for blue-collar
workers who I promised to fight for
they're growing faster than anyone else
thought possible nearly 5 million
Americans have been lifted off food
stamps
the US economy is growing almost twice
as fast today as when I took office and
we are considered far and away the
hottest economy anywhere in the world
not even close unemployment has reached
the lowest rate in over half a century
[Applause]
african-american Hispanic American and
Asian American unemployment have all
reached their lowest levels ever
recorded
unemployment for Americans with
disabilities has also reached an
all-time low
more people are working now than at any
time in the history of our country 157
million people at work we passed a
massive tax cut for working families and
doubled the child tax credit
we virtually ended the estate tax or
death tax as it is often called on small
businesses for ranches and also for
family farms
we eliminated the very unpopular
Obamacare individual mandate penalty
and you give critically ill patients
access to life-saving cures we passed
very importantly right to try
my administration has cut more
regulations in a short period of time
than any other administration during its
entire tenure
companies are coming back to our country
in large numbers thanks to our historic
reductions in taxes and regulations and
we have unleashed a revolution in
American energy the United States is now
the number one producer of oil and
natural gas anywhere in the world
and now for the first time in 65 years
we are a net exporter of energy
after 24 months of rapid progress our
economy is the envy of the world our
military is the most powerful on earth
by far and America
America is again winning each and every
day members of Congress the state of our
union is strong
[Applause]
that sounds so good
our country is vibrant and our economy
is thriving like never before when
Friday it was announced that we added
another three hundred and four thousand
jobs last month alone almost double the
number expected
an economic miracle is taking place in
the United States and the only thing
that can stop it are foolish Wars
politics or ridiculous partisan
investigations
if there is going to be peace and
legislation there cannot be war and
investigation it just doesn't work that
way we must be united at home to defeat
our adversaries abroad this new era of
cooperation can start with finally
confirming the more than 300 highly
qualified nominees who are still stuck
in the Senate in some cases years and
years waiting not right
the Senators failed to act on these
nominations which is unfair to the
nominees and very unfair to our country
now is the time for bipartisan action
believe it or not we have already proven
that that's possible in the last
Congress both parties came together to
pass unprecedented legislation to
confront the opioid crisis a sweeping
new farm bill historic VA reforms and
after four decades of rejection we
passed VA accountability so that we can
finally terminate those who mistreat our
wonderful veterans
and just weeks ago both parties united
for groundbreaking criminal justice
reform they said it couldn't be done
last year I heard through friends the
story of Alice Johnson I was deeply
moved in 1997 Alice was sentenced to
life in prison as a first-time
nonviolent drug offender over the next
22 years she became a prison minister
inspiring others to choose a better path
she had a big impact on that prison
population and far beyond Alice's story
underscores the disparities and
unfairness that can exist in criminal
sentencing and the need to remedy this
total injustice she served almost that
22 years and had expected to be in
prison for the remainder of her life in
June I commuted Alice's sense when I saw
Alice's beautiful family greener at the
prison gates hugging and kissing and
crying and laughing I knew I did
something right Alice is with us tonight
and she is a terrific woman
terrific Alice please
[Applause]
palace thank you for reminding us that
we always have the power to shape our
own destiny thank you very much Ellis
thank you very much inspired by stories
like Alice's my administration worked
closely with members of both parties to
sign the first-step Act into law
this legislation reformed sentencing
laws that have wrongly and
disproportionately harmed the
african-american community the
first-step Act gives nonviolent
offenders the chance to reenter society
as productive law-abiding citizens now
states across the country are following
our lead America is a nation that
believes in Redemption we are also
joined tonight by matthew charles from
tennessee in 1996 at the age of 30
matthew was sentenced to 35 years for
selling drugs and related offenses over
the next two decades he completed more
than 30 Bible studies became a law clerk
and mentored many of his fellow inmates
now Matthew is the very first person to
be released from prison under the first
step
Thank You Matthew welcome home now
Republicans and Democrats must join
forces again to confront an urgent
national crisis Congress has ten days
left to pass a bill that will fund our
government protect our homeland and
secure our very dangerous southern
border now is the time for Congress to
show the world that America is committed
to ending illegal immigration and
putting the ruthless coyote's cartels
drug dealers and human traffickers out
of business
as we speak large organized caravans are
on the march to the United States we
have just heard that Mexican cities in
order to remove the illegal immigrants
from their communities are getting
trucks and buses to bring them up to our
country in areas where there is little
border protection I have ordered another
three thousand seven hundred and fifty
troops to our southern border to prepare
for this tremendous onslaught this is a
moral issue the lawless state of our
southern border is a threat to the
safety security and financial well-being
of all America we have a moral duty to
create an immigration system that
protects the lives and jobs of our
citizens this includes our obligation to
the millions of immigrants living here
today who followed the rules and
respected our laws legal immigrants
enrich our nation and strengthen our
society in countless ways
I want people to come into our country
in the largest numbers ever but they
have to come in Legally
tonight I am asking you to defend our
very dangerous southern border out of
love and devotion to our fellow citizens
and to our country no issue better
illustrates the divide between America's
working class and America's political
class than illegal immigration wealthy
politicians and donors push for open
borders while living their lives behind
walls and gates and guards
meanwhile working-class Americans are
left to pay the price for mass illegal
immigration reduce jobs lower wages
overburdened schools hospitals that are
so crowded you can't get in increased
crime and a depleted social safety net
tolerance for illegal immigration is not
compassionate it is actually very cruel
one in three women is sexually assaulted
on the long journey north smugglers use
migrant children as human pawns to
exploit our laws and gain access to our
country human traffickers and sex
traffickers take advantage of the wide
open areas between our ports of entry to
smuggle thousands of young girls and
women into the United States and to sell
them into prostitution and modern-day
slavery
tens of thousands of innocent Americans
are killed by lethal drugs that cross
our border and flood into our cities
including meth heroin cocaine and
fentanyl the savage gang ms-13 now
operates in at least 20 different
American states and they almost all come
through our southern border just
yesterday an ms-13 gang member was taken
into custody for a fatal shooting on a
subway platform in New York City we are
removing these gang members by the
thousands but until we secure our border
they're going to keep streaming right
back in year after year countless
Americans are murdered by criminal
illegal aliens I've gotten to know many
wonderful angel moms and dads and
families no one should ever have to
suffer the horrible heartache that they
have had to endure here tonight is Debra
Bissell just three weeks ago Debra's
parents Gerald and Sharon were
burglarized
and shot to death in their Reno Nevada
home by an illegal alien they were in
their 80s and are survived by four
children 11 grandchildren and 20
great-grandchildren also here tonight
our Gerald and Sharon's granddaughter
Heather and great granddaughter Madison
- Deborah had their Madison please stand
few can understand your pain thank you
and thank you for being here thank you
very much
I will never forget and I will fight for
the memory of Gerald and share that it
should never happen again not one more
American life should be lost because our
nation failed to control
it's very dangerous border in the last
two years our brave ice officers made
two hundred and sixty-six thousand
arrests of criminal aliens including
those charged or convicted of nearly
100,000 assaults thirty thousand sex
crimes and four thousand killings or
murders we are joined tonight by one of
those law enforcement heroes ice Special
Agent Elvin Hernandez when Elvin
when Elvan was a boy he and his family
legally immigrated to the United States
from the Dominican Republic at the age
of eight Elvin told his dad he wanted to
become a special agent today he leads
investigations into the scourge of
international sex trafficking Elvin says
that if I can make sure these young
girls get their justice I've really done
my job thanks to his work and that of
his incredible colleagues more than 300
women and girls have been rescued from
bahara
of this terrible situation and more than
1500 sadistic traffickers have been put
behind bars
we will always support the brave men and
women of law enforcement
and I pledge to you tonight that I will
never abolish our heroes from ice thank
you
my administration has sent to Congress a
common-sense proposal to end the crisis
on the southern border it includes
humanitarian assistance more law
enforcement drug detection at our ports
closing loopholes that enable child
smuggling and plans for a new physical
barrier or wall to secure the vast areas
between our ports of entry in the past
most of the people in this room voted
for a wall but the proper wall never got
built I will get it built
this is a smart strategic see-through
steel barrier not just a simple concrete
wall it will be deployed in the areas
identified by the border agents as
having the greatest need and these
agents will tell you where walls go up
illegal crossings go way way down
San Diego used to have the most illegal
border crossings in our country in
response a strong security wall was put
in place this powerful barrier almost
completely ended illegal crossings the
border city of El Paso Texas used to
have extremely high rates of violent
crime one of the highest in the entire
country and considered one of our
nation's most dangerous cities now
immediately upon its building with a
powerful barrier in place El Paso is one
of the safest cities in our country
simply put walls work and walls save
lives
so let's work together compromise and
reach a deal that will truly make
America safe as we work to defend our
people safety we must also ensure our
economic resurgence continues at a rapid
pace
no one has benefited more from a
thriving economy than women who have
filled 58% of the newly created jobs
last year
[Applause]
you weren't supposed to do that thank
you very much thank you very much all
Americans can be proud that we have more
women in the workforce than ever before
[Applause]
don't sit yet you know like this
and exactly one century after Congress
passed the constitutional amendment
giving women the right to vote we also
have more women serving in Congress than
at any time before
[Applause]
[Music]
that's great
very good and congratulations that's
great as part of our commitment to
improving opportunity for women
everywhere this Thursday we are
launching the first-ever government-wide
initiative focused on economic
empowerment for women in developing
countries to build on to build on our
incredible economic success one priority
is parama reversing decades of
calamitous trade policies so bad we are
now making it clear to China that after
years of targeting our industries and
stealing our intellectual property the
theft of American jobs and wealth has
come to an end
[Applause]
therefore we recently imposed tariffs on
two hundred and fifty billion dollars of
Chinese goods and now our Treasury is
receiving billions and billions of
dollars but I don't blame China for
taking advantage of us I blame our
leaders and representatives for allowing
this travesty to happen I have great
respect for President Xi and we are now
working on a new trade deal with China
but it must include real structural
change to end unfair trade practices
reduce our chronic trade deficit and
protect American jobs
another historic trade blunder was the
catastrophe known as NAFTA I have met
the men and women of Michigan Ohio
Pennsylvania Indiana New Hampshire and
many other states whose dreams were
shattered by the signing of NAFTA for
years politicians promised them they
would renegotiate for a better deal
but no one ever tried until now our new
US Mexico Canada Agreement the u.s. MCA
will replace NAFTA and deliver for
American workers like they haven't had
delivered to for a long time I hope you
can pass the u.s. MCA into law so that
we can bring back our manufacturing jobs
and even greater numbers expand American
agriculture protect intellectual
property and ensure that more cars are
proudly stamped with our four beautiful
words made in the USA
[Applause]
tonight I am also asking you to pass the
United States reciprocal trade act so
that if another country places and
unfair tariffs on an American product we
can charge them the exact same tariff on
the exact same product that they sell to
us
both parties should be able to unite for
a great rebuilding of America's
crumbling infrastructure
I know that Congress is eager to pass an
infrastructure bill and I am eager to
work with you or legislation to deliver
new and important infrastructure
investment including investments in the
cutting edge industries of the future
this is not an option this is a
necessity
the next major priority for me and for
all of us should be to lower the cost of
health care and prescription drugs and
to protect patients with pre-existing
conditions
[Applause]
already as a result of my
administration's efforts in 2018 drug
prices experienced their single largest
decline in 46 years
but we must do more it's unacceptable
that Americans pay vastly more than
people in other countries for the exact
same drugs often made in the exact same
place this is wrong this is unfair and
together we will stop it and we'll stop
it fast
I am asking Congress to pass legislation
that finally takes on the problem of
global freeloading and delivers fairness
and price transparency for American
patients finally
we should also require drug companies
insurance companies and hospitals to
disclose real prices to foster
competition and bring costs way down
no force in history has done more to
advance the human condition than
American freedom in recent years
in recent years we have made remarkable
progress in the fight against HIV and
AIDS scientific breakthroughs have
brought a once distant dream Within
Reach
my budget will ask Democrats and
Republicans to make the needed
commitment to eliminate the HIV epidemic
in the United States within ten years we
have made incredible strides incredible
together we will defeat age in America
and beyond
tonight I am also asking you to join me
in another fight that all Americans can
get behind the fight against childhood
cancer
joining Melania in the gallery this
evening is a very brave 10 year old girl
Gracie line every birthday
[Applause]
hi grace
every birthday since she was four grace
asked her friends to donate to st.
Jude's Children's Hospital she did not
know that one day she might be a patient
herself that's what happened last year
grace was diagnosed with brain cancer
immediately she began radiation
treatment at the same time she rallied
her community and raised more than 40
thousand dollars for the fight against
cancer
when grace completed treatment last fall
her doctors and nurses cheered they
loved her they still loved her with
tears in their eyes as she hung up a
poster that read last day of chemo
thank you very much grace you are a
great inspiration to everyone in this
room thank you very much many childhood
cancers have not seen new therapies in
decades my budget will ask Congress for
500 million dollars over the next ten
years to fund this critical life-saving
research to help support working parents
the time has come to pass school choice
for Americans children
I am also proud to be the first
president to include a my budget a plan
for nationwide paid family leave so that
every new parent has the chance to bond
with their newborn child
there could be no greater contrast to
the beautiful image of a mother holding
her infant child then the chilling
displays our nation saw in recent days
lawmakers in New York cheered with
delight upon the passage of legislation
that would allow a baby to be ripped
from the mother's womb moments from
birth these are living feeling beautiful
babies who will never get the chance to
share their love and their dreams with
the world and then we had the case of
the governor of Virginia where he stated
he would execute a baby after birth to
defend the dignity of every person I am
asking Congress to pass legislation to
prohibit the late term abortion of
children
let us work together to build a culture
that cherishes innocent life
[Applause]
and let us reaffirm a fundamental truth
all children born and unborn are made in
the holy image of God the final part of
my agenda is to protect American
security over the last two years we have
begun to fully rebuild the United States
military with 700 billion dollars last
year and 716 billion dollars this year
we are also getting other nations to pay
their fair share
for years the United States was being
treated very unfairly by friends of ours
members of NATO but now we have secured
over the last couple of years more than
100 billion dollars of increase in
defense spending from our NATO allies
they said it couldn't be done
as part of our military buildup the
United States is developing a
state-of-the-art missile defense system
under my administration we will never
apologize for advancing America's
interests for example decades ago the
United States entered into a treaty with
Russia in which we agreed to limit and
reduce our missile capability well we
followed the agreement and the rules to
the letter Russia repeatedly violated
its terms it's been going on for many
years that is why I announced that the
United States is officially withdrawing
from the intermediate-range nuclear
forces treaty or INF treaty perhaps
[Applause]
we really have no choice
perhaps we can negotiate a different
agreement adding China and others or
perhaps we can't in which case we will
out spend and out-innovate all others by
far
as part of a bold new diplomacy we
continue our historic push for peace on
the Korean Peninsula our hostages have
come home nuclear testing has stopped
and there has not been a missile launch
in more than 15 months if I had not been
elected president of the United States
we would right now in my opinion be in a
major war with North Korea
much work remains to be done but my
relationship with Kim jong-un is a good
one
chairman Kim and I will meet again on
February 27th and 28th in Vietnam
two weeks ago the United States
officially recognized the legitimate
government of Venezuela and its new
president Ron
we stand with the Venezuelan people in
their noble quest for freedom and we
condemned the brutality of the Maduro
regime who socialist policies have
turned that nation from being the
wealthiest in South America into a state
of abject poverty and despair here in
the United States we are alarmed by the
new calls to adopt socialism in our
country
America was founded on liberty and
independence and not government coercion
domination and control we are born free
and we will stay free
tonight we renew our resolve that
America will never be a socialist
country
[Applause]
one of the most complex set of
challenges we face and have for many
years is in the Middle East
our approach is based on principle
realism not discredited theories that
have failed for decades to yield
progress for this reason my
administration recognized the true
capital of Israel and proudly opened the
American Embassy in Jersey
our brave troops have now been fighting
in the Middle East for almost 19 years
in Afghanistan and Iraq nearly 7,000
American heroes have given their lives
more than 52,000 Americans have been
badly wounded
we have spent more than seven trillion
dollars in fighting wars in the Middle
East as a candidate for president I
loudly pledged a new approach great
nations do not fight endless wars
when I took office Isis controlled more
than 20,000 square miles in Iraq and
Syria just two years ago today we have
liberated virtually all of the territory
from the grip of these blood thirsty
monsters now as we work with our allies
to destroy the remnants of Isis it is
time to give our brave warriors in Syria
a warm welcome home I have also
accelerated our negotiations to reach if
possible a political settlement in
Afghanistan the opposing side is also
very happy to be negotiating our troops
have fought with unmatched valor and
thanks to their bravery we are now able
to pursue a possible political solution
to this long and bloody conflict
in Afghanistan my administration is
holding constructive talks with a number
of Afghan groups including the Taliban
as we make progress in these
negotiations we will be able to reduce
our troops presence and focus on counter
terrorism and we will indeed focus on
counter terrorism we do not know whether
we'll achieve an agreement but we do
know that after two decades of war the
hour has come to at least try for peace
and the other side would like to do the
same thing it's time
above all friend and foe alike was never
doubt this nation's power and will to
defend our people eighteen years ago
violent terrorists attacked the USS Cole
and last month American forces killed
one of the leaders of that attack
[Applause]
we are honored to be joined tonight by
Tom Whibley
whose son Navy Seaman Craig Whibley was
one of the 17 sailors we tragically lost
Tom we vow to always remember the heroes
of the USS Cole
my administration has acted decisively
to confront the world's leading state
sponsor of Terror the radical regime in
Iran it is a radical regime they do bad
bad things to ensure this corrupt
dictatorship never acquires nuclear
weapons I withdrew the United States
from the disastrous Iran nuclear deal
and last fall we put in place the
toughest sanctions ever imposed by us on
a country we will not avert our eyes
from a regime that chants death to
America and threatens genocide against
the Jewish people
we must never ignore the vile poison of
anti-semitism or those who spread its
venomous Creed with one voice we must
confront this hatred anywhere and
everywhere it occurs just months ago
eleven Jewish Americans were viciously
murdered in an anti-semitic attack on
the Tree of Life synagogue in Pittsburgh
SWAT officer Timothy Matson raced into
the gunfire and was shot seven times
chasing down the killer and he was very
successful Timothy has just had his 12th
surgery and he's going in for many more
but he made the trip to be here with us
tonight
officer Matson please
[Applause]
thank you we are forever grateful thank
you very much
tonight we are also joined by Pittsburgh
survivor
Judah salmon he arrived at the synagogue
as the massacre began but not only did
Judah narrowly escaped death last fall
more than seven decades ago he narrowly
survived the Nazi concentration camps
today is Judas 81st birthday
[Applause]
[Applause]
they wouldn't do that for me Judith
Judis says he can still remember the
exact moment nearly 75 years ago after
10 months in a concentration camp when
he and his family were put on a train
and told they were going to another camp
suddenly the train screeched to a very
strong halt as soldier appeared Judah's
family braced for the absolute worse
than his father cried out with joy
it's the Americans it's the Americans
thank you a second Holocaust survivor
who was here tonight
Joshua Kaufman was a prisoner at Dachau
he remembers watching through a hole in
the wall of a cattle car as American
soldiers rolled in with tanks for me
Joshua recalls the American soldiers
were proof that God exists and they came
down from the sky they came down from
heaven I began this evening by honoring
three soldiers who fought on d-day in
the Second World War one of them was
Herman as I Chico but there is more to
Herman story a year after he stormed the
beaches of Normandy Herman was one of
the American soldiers who helped
liberate Dachau
[Applause]
he was one of the Americans who helped
rescue Joshua from that hell on earth
almost 75 years later Herrmann and
Joshua are both together in the gallery
tonight seated side by side here in the
home of American freedom Herrmann and
Joshua your presence this evening is
very much appreciated thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you when American soldiers set out
beneath the dark skies over the English
Channel in the early hours of d-day 1944
they were just young men of 18 and 19
hurtling on fragile landing craft toward
the most momentous battle in the history
of war they did not know if they would
survive the hour they did not know if
they would grow old but they knew that
America had to prevail their cause was
this nation and generations yet unborn
why did they do it they did it for
America they did it for us everything
that has come since our triumph over
communism our giant leaps of science and
discovery our unrivaled progress towards
equality and justice all of it is
possible thanks to the blood and tears
and courage and vision of the Americans
who came before think of this Capitol
think of this very chamber where
lawmakers before you voted to end
slavery to build the railroads and the
highways and defeat fascism to secure
civil rights and to face down evil
empires here tonight we have legislators
from across this magnificent Republic
you have come from the rocky shores of
Maine and the volcanic Peaks of Hawaii
from the snowy woods of Wisconsin and
the red deserts of Arizona from the
green farms of Kentucky and the golden
beaches of California together we
represent the most extraordinary nation
in all of history what will we do with
this moment how will we be remembered I
asked the men and women of this Congress
looked at the opportunities before us
our most thrilling achievements are
still ahead our most exciting journeys
still await our biggest victories are
still to come we have not yet begun to
dream we must choose whether we are
defined by our differences or whether we
dare to transcend them we must choose
whether we squander our great
inheritance or whether we proudly
declare that we are Americans we do the
incredible we defy the impossible we
conquer the unknown this is the time to
reignite the American imagination this
is the time to search for the tallest
summit and set our sights on the
brightest star this is the time to
rekindle the bonds of love and loyalty
and memory that link us together as
citizens as neighbors as Patriots this
is our future
our fate and our choice to make I am
asking you to choose greatness no matter
the trial
we face no matter the challenges to come
we must go forward together we must keep
America first in our hearts we must keep
freedom alive in our souls and we must
always keep faith in America's destiny
that one nation under God must be the
hope and the promise and the light and
the glory among all the nations of the
world
thank you god bless you and God bless
america
thank you